[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight here in cable news we really try
not to over promise at the outset of a
show but we got to be clear with you
this evening there's a lot going on at
this very moment the house
representatives is doing a mark-up of
its impeachment resolution opening
statements were held a short time ago
we're monitoring that we'll bring you
highlights as they happen later in the
hour plus all of the top moments from
the DOJ inspector general's testimony to
the Senate that's also ahead but first
tonight thanks to the Department of
Justice IG report the one released
yesterday we now know for certain what
was those who are paying attention
fairly obvious for a long time in fact
from the beginning we now know the steel
dossier played a central role in the
genesis of the beginning of the Russia
hoax the dossier was used to justify
extensive spying on an innocent American
citizen that would be former naval
officer and Annapolis graduate Carter
page the top two leaders at the FBI were
closely involved in the decision to do
this other powerful people including a
former director of the CIA knew it was
happening and then lied to cover it up
later all of that was confirmed
yesterday by the I G's report the report
was a disaster for the credibility of
our bureaucratic class in Washington but
it's also a big big problem for the
American news media they were exposed as
liars and know-nothings as well we could
give you million examples of this but
we're gonna give us a few because they
paint the picture here's one in early
2018 Washington Post intelligence and
national security correspondent Shane
Harris lectured Kim Strasser the Wall
Street Journal someone who's frequently
on this show about how little she knew
about the story yes she wrote
condescendingly I am Telling You the
dossier was not used as the basis for a
FISA warrant on Carter page end quote
now you may wonder how he could have
known that since the fight sir warrant
was classified
he's never explained but it doesn't
matter it was false and now we know it's
false but here's the key Harris has not
apologized or even acknowledged his role
in repeating false it's democracy dies
in the darkness right no his motives
remain shrouded in darkness
or take NBC News's so-called
intelligence correspondent Kendall a
nyan a consistent shill for the Intel
agencies in the summer of 2018 Delaney
and smugly tweeted this quote Trump is
wrong about Carter page in the dossier
and the FISA warrant end quote
except it looks like Trump was right
about Carter page and the dossier and
the FISA warrant and Kendall a nyan and
his sources in the Intel community were
completely wrong CNN NEWSROOM anchor and
chief national security correspondent
Jim sciutto meanwhile actually did admit
that the Steele dossier might have been
used for the fighter warrant but don't
be impressed
Sheila lectured readers that quote the
FBI would corroborate information in the
dossier on its own before using such
Intel justify the FISA War in other
words you can believe your government
ladies and gentlemen and anyone who
doubts that as a bad person of course
that was a lie too it didn't happen in
fact just the opposite happened we now
know thanks the IG report that the FBI
hid information showing the dossier was
false
they didn't confirm the information they
pretended it was real when they know it
wasn't and they continued to use it to
read the FISA warrant totally dishonest
behavior pseudo was wrong at best did he
issue a correction of course he didn't
he was too busy tweeting a Nancy Pelosi
quote about how solemn impeachment was
wish hill but it just seemed a little
unfair to focus on Jim shooter but
finish as he is he was merely following
the lead of almost everybody else had
seen it all of whom were frantically
trying to convince you that the dossier
was totally irrelevant to the FISA
warrant right you know a lot of people
will focus on the dossier a lot of
people will focus on on a FISA of Carter
page and they'll say they were spying on
a campaign but at the beginning this is
all about what Russia was doing and now
Republicans were trying to claim that
the dossier was key to getting the FISA
this surveillance warrant for Carter
page but the Democrats memo clearly
shows that that it wasn't a key that
there was more to the information that
they have even the earlier version of
the redacted file authorization to be
had enough information in it to indicate
that the dossier was certainly not used
as the primary source
ouch that has a weathered well has it
everything you just saw turned out to be
false if not outright lying there's no
debate about it we know now it was wrong
has seen and retracted it or apologized
I'm sorry that's that's a rhetorical
question
apologies require introspection and
decency integrity even at CNN they are
by contrast doubling down watched on
LeMond explained that by definition
everything CNN reported was true so how
is the White House in the Republican
Party dealing with the articles of
impeachment and an Inspector General
report that debunked their conspiracy
theories gaslighting by the way there
was no spying of course the FBI obtained
proper warrants you should read the
report facts first none of that is true
the report found that the launch of the
Russia investigation was legally sound
unbiased and that no spying occurred
that is the God's honest truth read the
report if you don't believe me read the
report says Don LeMond warily just read
it just read it
facts first says Don LeMond that's kind
of Donna LeMans motto wizened old news
man that he is facts facts and still
more facts done them on can't get enough
facts in fact when it comes to facts Don
lands like a fat kid the concession
stand he wants the biggest helping of
facts he can get his gobbles him on down
if Don LeMans world facts are delicious
your opinion has no place Governor
Cuomo's brother agrees with that unlike
you he went to Yale University in New
Haven Connecticut it mitad purely by
pluck and cleverness and hard work so
he's smart enough to know lying when he
sees it and non partisan enough to
report it without fear or favor watch
Trump is the victim all right that was
what was promised from this IGS report
476 pages no Trump as victim Trump even
says that that's what this says it
doesn't he's lying to you about the
report please do yourself the favor do
the homework he's lying to you
yeah do the homework demands Chris Cuomo
do the homework read the IG report but
you got to wonder let's be honest here
it's Chris Cuomo really living up to his
own standards as Chris Cuomo actually
read the IG report come on now be honest
or is it possible that Chris Cuomo is
assistant promised to read the IG report
give him a summary but then got stuck in
a super long holiday season line at
Starbucks and forgot to do it and then
maybe in a last-minute panic which is
understandable we're not judging here
but you know under the circumstances
maybe told a few white lies to chris
cuomo about what the report actually
said maybe that happened we're not sure
that's what happened obviously we're not
going to judge if it did but it's
certainly one possible explanation we do
know this
unless he is a pathological liar chris
cuomo didn't actually read the IG report
he couldn't have otherwise he would not
be able to sit in a television studio
stare into the camera and pretend that
the Justice Department's inspector
general just confirmed what CNN has been
telling you for three years he couldn't
have said that because it's absolutely
not what happened yesterday not even
close